hey stead of files welcome to another
instant trailer review today we're
taking a look at Lucy very excited for
this new Leucippus on film
oh yes and who wouldn't be after last
year's of the family I fear all ready
for another loop Poisson fun yeah so but
he did do the Fifth Element yeah I mean
angel a he does have we pretty much
determined that he is the Michael Bay of
France more or less yeah so I mean
Scarlett Johansson you know she she had
a crazy night last night let's let's go
back to that Club shot for a second cuz
I mean I love that the cinematography is
great for that yeah good set up for the
story and I mean he's casting Scarlett
Johansson in this he's known for his
strong female leads and absolutely yet
again going with that which is great for
cinema intro hands I mean after her
involvement with the Avengers and
everything she's just ready to kiss our
ass yeah okay so she's a drug mule for
the mob and we should say this is
actually said in 2069 yeah you you
wouldn't really guess that based on a
lot that we're seeing but the plot
synopsis tells us that
set in type image yeah okay this really
excites me okay this is min-sik Choi
he's like one of the a list actors in
Korea he's an old boy you know I saw the
devil he's a fantastic element to heaven
yeah
and so she clearly mixed with the wrong
people so the plot basically is she
smuggled these drugs she's a drug mule
and they basically after they were
inside her they infected her and gave
her superhuman abilities okay and let me
just give a quick shout out light never
fades one of our commenters on the
trailer says reminds me of limitless but
with a whole new added spectrum of
badass so excited and I don't know about
you but I limitless is yeah we're about
to see it get very very limitless I
guess yeah even the nice shiny amazing
that's absolutely great
so it basically gets into the idea that
you can open up more of your mind you
know use them a hundred percent of it
where we couldn't wait all these an
instant what's the famous quote
such and such person yeah I mean yeah
and tie they used to full effect I mean
that's that's the Taipei 101 in that
last shot there Luke the son had a heck
of a time shooting this they're actually
the paparazzi were invading almost every
single shot with Scarlett Johansson's
who said the only shot in Taipei for
home for like 11 days well actually and
that was that was actually too long for
the sounds like you see in this scene
right here I think it's gonna be it's
gonna be taken it's gonna be a revenge
flick and as the trailer goes on I think
it shifts to to a different story
yeah it's got some great visuals and
Morgan Freeman reads in there too it's a
different role for him though you know
he's playing somebody in charge it seems
like yeah he doesn't do that and of
course I mean a lot of it's still gonna
be set in Paris which you would expect
another another fun comment warped soul
said it scary with a drug problem and I
mean so she's gonna be not only like who
see the actions in Fatah but she's also
gonna actually have these superpowers
yeah maybe some in this is where I think
the the trailer just completely gets a
little crazy okay I think us in the room
we disagreed a little bit with whether
we love this or I was this is just a
little bit too much I mean it was cool
but I don't it worries me a little sure
thing for me so many Lucas on films like
try to have it both ways they try to
exist in our world but the action is
just so outrageous than preposterous
that I normally get taken out of it look
who we have right there if we go back
okay who's that
uh-oh looked it looked like Nathan
Fillion but that is Nathan Fillion but
go back to the freight before okay the
frame before this yeah okay that's
Nathan Fillion look like right there
okay side profile News affiliate the
poor man's Navy alien alright we'll take
them yeah I mean so yeah she's some
great visuals that yeah she's seeing the
world that we just don't see our eyes
don't allow that okay this is awesome I
mean they're obviously trying to do like
as many joint productions as possible
they're tapping the Korea market and the
Taiwanese market which is you know this
film is probably going to open in Japan
or and China
I switch
okay this is cool I mean yeah this is
the part that lost you kind of love it
lost me because I didn't I didn't see
this coming I thought
from reading the description hearing
about what it was gonna be about who's
just gonna be a straight-up revengeful
and I mean I I do like this angle it
just caught me off by surprise
yeah but I mean it does just look
fantastic yeah it definitely does have a
great feel about it so yeah that's Lucy
it's coming out in August overall are
you excited for this film I am I'm a big
action guy so I'm definitely gonna go
see it what about you
yeah and in fact exactly I'm afraid I'm
gonna have to say I'm already loving
Lucy so yeah well we'll have to wait to
August to see how it pans out but
looking good so far
yeah I'm excited thanks for joining us
for another incident trailer review I'm
Jas and ohm's AK thanks for watching